>> KANNINEN: Hi. I'm Matt Kanninen. I'm a
software developer with MySpace. I'm here
to show you the application we developed for
the Android platform. First, we'll go to home
page. They have features of the core social
networking functions of MySpace, including
searching and add friends; commenting on photos,
blogs and profiles; messaging; and viewing
and uploading photos. First, we'll view our
friend status.
Next, I'll update mine.
Next, we'll upload a photo to MySpace. I'm
accessing the phone's library right here,
choosing a photo and uploading it to MySpace.
We can view the uploaded photo in its album
right here. And there we go. We're excited
about the Android platform and we developed
this application to take advantage of the
rich device capabilities that presents to
us. We've previously developed applications
for other mobile platforms and Android was
the logical next step. Our application began
as a part of our iPhone App. We're able to
use--we start out using the same assets, we
consumed the same SOAP web services and we
were able to take the XML layout files from
that application and perform accessibility
transforms on them to generate the initial
app for this application. We used our Apache
Access to generate stubs from the WSDL files
and we use K sub 2 to perform the SOAP metric
calls.